let's start today with mass shootings
you know whenever there is news of a
specific mass shooting understandably
the focus becomes the facts of that
particular situation when we had the
buffalo mass shooting where this 18 year
old was targeting black people this was
in buffalo new york not this past
weekend but the previous one we
immediately understandably correctly
spoke about the details of that incident
where did the individual come from what
were the motivations of the individual
who were the victims of what was the
response what has been the political
response and on and on
and whenever we do that
we often will lose
the perspective
that there are so many of these mass
shootings in the united states that it
would almost be a full daily podcast
just to keep up with the mass shootings
that are taking place in the united
states now i spoke to a couple of people
yesterday just casually texted friends
and said hey i'm researching for a story
i'm doing
if i just asked how many mass shootings
have there been in 2022 so far without
looking anything up what's your sense
and many of them wrote back something
like well i'm aware of like three or
four specific ones that like made the
news to the to the threshold that i was
aware of it so there's probably been
like 40 or 50 because we have a huge
mass shooting problem here in the united
states we have had as of yesterday
210
mass shootings in the united states so
far it's only may
it's only may and we have had 210 mass
shootings never mind individual
shootings as well as shootings in which
two but not more than two people were
injured or killed remember if one person
shoots two people
by most metrics that's not considered a
mass shooting you could argue that it
should be
um but depending on the archive or or
statistics you look at it only is
considered a mass shooting when three or
four people
are
injured or killed and bearing that in
mind if you go to the gun violence
archive and you can download a
spreadsheet of this
you will see
210 actually in fact
i believe the number is now 211. since i
last looked at this there's there was a
mass shooting yesterday in south
carolina north charleston where five
people were injured so it is now 211
mass shootings in the united states
every single one of these is a story
that impacts
many people families friends co-workers
etc if we pick a random one of these
just for example the the
second most recent one
um which one i looked yesterday was the
most recent one when you look at that
one that was in goshen indiana by the
way a place i've been to
and um
it took place
on rosemary
court
um
when you look at the victims there was a
17 year old male who was killed
there was a female injured another
female injured another female injured
and the suspect is believed to be a 20
year old
male
who was also killed according to the
information that we have here and for
every single one of these typically
there is a media source that you can
look at in this case the media source
takes us
uh looks like it's a facebook page a
release from the goshen police
department talking about how an
emergency call was received
that a shooting took place at a
residence
five individuals were injured according
to the report emts were sent out two
injured females were airlifted to a
trauma hospital in fort wayne one was
taken to a hospital in south bend an
injured male was taken to goshen
hospital but has been declared deceased
and one male was pronounced deceased at
the scene
every single one of these is a story
that affects so many people's lives and
most of these don't even make national
news
and one of the things i've talked about
before uh npr also about nine days ago
did a story on this at that point nine
days ago there had been 198 mass
shootings now we're already up to 211.
whenever there's a news story
that doesn't have a clear beginning
middle and end
it often will not make it into the news
or whenever there's an event that like
that so when we talk about well
there was a shooting where one person
was killed and it gets more attention
than thousands of people in the united
states or however many are going hungry
whereas that's a major story how do we
still have hunger in a country as rich
as the united states well it comes to
what makes a good story for corporate
media and i've spoken about this before
uh terrorist attacks weather events
individual shootings votes on a
particular bill
those have a defined typically beginning
middle and end
they have very clear players
there are very clear sort of goal posts
for what is the coverage expected to be
and how are these topics discussed
uh regular corporate media is not really
set up to talk about
hunger in the united states
in an ongoing way okay there's a food
stamp bill democrats for republicans i
guess whatever but
the news corporate for-profit news is
not really set up to talk about that uh
uh malaria in africa
um
dysentery and
these are not the types of stories
that corporate media is designed to
address and even when you look at the
politics the political stories
the
intractable and corrosive nature
of how we select our representatives and
then how they don't really represent our
interests that's an ongoing and major
story arguably it's one of the
fundamental stories about how american
politics is broken it doesn't really
have a clear beginning middle and end
and as a result it's why you often don't
see much about it in corporate news so
to go back to the beginning 210 211 now
mass shootings in the united states and
it is not even memorial day hey this is
just uh the best this is another
reminder
of how
all of these supposed principles of the
modern republican right
are meaningless
to them they only care about what is
good for me right now as you might
remember
when we were getting closer to the 2020
election it was republicans united that
mail-in ballots are bad
mail-in ballots help democrats mail-in
ballots allow democrats to commit fraud
and on and on and on and in the
immediate aftermath of the 2020 election
it was republicans saying we've got to
stop the count or start the count or
count these correctly or that but the
point was the mail-in ballots are bad
for democracy they could be criminal
they are fraudulent and they just must
be stopped because that's that's what
the democrats do
well now
they are still counting ballots in the
pennsylvania republican senate primary
this was the race we covered live last
tuesday and which on wednesday i told
you
memit oz is just slightly ahead of dave
mccormick but they're still counting
ballots well now
democrat i'm sorry republicans
candidates and the parties are arguing
amongst themselves count the mail in
ballots don't count them include these
throw these out because they don't have
a date on them
they don't care about the principles all
they care about is what helps me right
now there's an article
from the new york times mccormick sues
to count undated mail-in ballots
trailing oz in pennsylvania senate race
wait wait a second hold on
so
in 2020 the problem was
any
irregular ballot like it doesn't have a
date on it or whatever the case may be
you've got to throw it out that's bad
stuff
now
the undated mail-in ballots are believed
to be likely good for dave mccormick and
not so good for amendments oh now we've
got to sue we'd better count those
mail-in ballots even if they don't have
a date as irregular as it is for the
ballot to not have a date written in
we must make sure that the will of the
voter is represented and that the vote
is counted but you guys were just
against that
david mccormick is trying to close the
gap against mehmet oz in the undecided
republican primary contest in uh this is
neil vigdor in the new york times in a
lawsuit filed monday in pennsylvania the
republican senate candidate david
mccormick demanded that undated mail-in
ballots should be counted in his primary
race against celebrity physician mehmet
oz whom he trailed by less than a
thousand votes
mccormick asked the court of
pennsylvania to allow election officials
in all 67 counties to accept mail-in
ballots from voters who turned them in
by the may 17 deadline but didn't write
the date on the outer return envelopes
that step is required by law
one that republicans have fought to
preserve it's been republi republicans
in pennsylvania and other states
who have argued for 2020
if there's no date written on the
outside
you put that in the trash you cover it
in
rocket fuel and you burn it we don't
count it
but now all of a sudden mccormick wants
it counted
okay
um
arguing
the ballots were indisputably submitted
on time
they were date stamped upon receipt
and no fraud or irregularity has been
alleged
hmm
in the mccormick campaign's lawsuit
mr hicks who is this uh lawyer
took the opposite view of mail-in
ballots saying the election boards in
allegheny county in western pennsylvania
and blair county have balked at counting
the undated ballots those counties he
said were delaying taking action until
after tuesday when they are required to
report unofficial results to the state
the board's refusal to count the ballots
at issue violates the protections of the
right to vote under the federal civil
rights act and pennsylvania constitution
whoa that's
that's pretty serious now you might
remember that the very same lawyer was
part of a group of lawyers that trump
hired to challenge mail-in ballots in
the 2020 election the same lawyer
now saying count all the ballots was
part of a group of lawyers saying don't
count them in november of 2020 when he
worked for donald trump uh as a reminder
here is dave mccormick on election night
saying hey you know what we've still got
mail-in ballots coming we might still be
able to win this thing
now we're gonna
we're gonna win this campaign we're
gonna win this campaign
and uh and tomorrow right now we have
tens of thousands
of mail-in ballots that have not been
counted right that are gonna need to be
counted beginning tomorrow
and uh and so that unfortunately we're
not gonna have resolution tonight okay
so now mail-in ballots are good what is
the takeaway the takeaway these people
are pathetic they don't really have
principles it's whatever is good for me
whatever is good for me is the principle
we'll see ultimately who wins this one
but just remember this just remember
this when they start making all sorts of
claims about mail-in ballots in november
monday memorial day we're doing our
one-day membership special make sure
you're on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
if you are you'll be notified monday
morning of how to take advantage of this
great one-day membership discount
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
let's talk next about some incredible
statements from marjorie taylor green
and tucker carlson both of which relate
to really serious political and media
issues here in the united states first
of all
radical repugnant retrograde republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green
complained that white supremacists
are being targeted
when it comes to mass shootings and
domestic terror you have to see this to
believe it marjorie taylor green saying
you know there's all these different
shooters and people doing bad stuff some
of them are black and all this different
stuff and they only want to target the
white supremacists but as usual it's all
in the details listen to what she had to
say and then we'll talk about it dale i
mean not sorry not on the jail on the
bill or this domestic terrorism um new
bill that came out for the department of
justice and jerry nadler was on the
house floor and he was talking about
white supremacy and he was bringing up
the terrible shooting that happened in
new york but totally ignoring the
shooting that happened in california um
that i think involved an asian man that
was a shooter totally ignoring the guy
that drove his car uh black man that
drove his car through a christmas parade
killing people and was a racist himself
completely ignoring ignoring the black
man that did the new york subway
shooting you know these people are all
guilty of these crimes and it's not
about rape it shouldn't be about race um
but they're clearly racist as well so it
so white supremacy shouldn't be the main
target we should be more concerned about
the legal invasion at the border the
crime happening every single day on our
streets and especially in cities like
chicago we should we should go after
criminals that break the law and not not
pursue people based on their skin color
and and how they vote
okay now of course people aren't being
pursued by the criminal justice system
based on their skin color or how they
vote but let's go through her claims one
by one she mentions the california asian
man shooter
that was a shooting at a taiwanese
church in california one person was
killed and five were wounded it's being
investigated as a hate crime and it was
a 68 year old shooter motivated by the
political tensions between china and
taiwan according to authorities there's
no media narrative there's no political
narrative in the united states
meant to
activate or uh
inspire any kind of uh tensions between
chinese and taiwanese people living in
the united states you don't turn on fox
news and see
instigative rhetoric about china and
taiwan
such that it would inspire shooters or
whatever the case may be there's really
no conversation to be had there about
american political discourse and
american media
we every once in a while will say oh
what what is china thinking about when
it comes to taiwan but there is no big
media political story that in the united
states would have inspired this shooting
so why would we be talking about it in
the same terms then marjorie taylor
green says well the black man that drove
his car
through a christmas parade who was a
racist okay
that's the waukesha christmas parade
attack from november
the driver of an suv plowed through a
christmas parade
killed six people and injured 62
terrible tragic incident and we know
that the perpetrator used the same car
to hit his ex-girlfriend 21 days earlier
it's believed that the driver acted
alone didn't even know anyone at the
parade wasn't targeting any particular
group of people at the parade the motive
is not equivalent it is true
that the guy was black
it's true that he had a history of
social media posts that were
anti-semitic and advocated for violence
against jews and white people and wrote
positive stuff about hitler disgusting
person no doubt about it there is no
evidence that the incident is related to
the ideology there just isn't any
evidence so why would we talk about it
in the same way
lastly
marjorie mentions the new york subway
shooting who was also a black man that
was six weeks ago that's the 2022 new
york city subway shooting reportedly uh
the man is 60 a 62 year old black
nationalist who put on a gas mask threw
two smoke grenades and fired more than
30 rounds from a handgun nobody died
fortunately 29 were injured horrible
incident
the believed shooter would sometimes
post
homophobic rants online
misogynistic rants online rants uh uh
targeting uh blacks hispanics whites all
sorts of different things anti-semitic
believed link to black nationalism great
talk about it talk about it no manifesto
but we've got some of this uh
a paper trail for lack of a better term
uh black nationalism is a tiny movement
there's no political party pushing the
ideology of black nationalism that's it
i mean i'm against any violent movement
but there is no story here
like what happened with the buffalo
shooter where we have seen years now of
a combined political and right-wing
media effort
to talk about this exact ideology that
was in the manifesto lastly marjorie
mentions and we should focus if we
really want to talk about this stuff we
should be focusing on the illegal
invasion at the border
immigrants
documented and undocumented commit crime
in the united states at a lower rate
than domestically born citizens so by
the math of it
that is not where you should focus if
you want to stop crime in the united
states because both documented and
undocumented immigrants commit crime at
a lower rate than
american-born
americans for lack of a better term so
it's a weird thing to insert into the
discussion so why are white supremacists
being targeted well
they're being targeted because law
enforcement
and our intelligence agencies have
indicated this is a major threat
and we quite literally found the
manifesto of the buffalo shooter where
he was parroting the exact stuff that
we've been hearing on tucker carlson and
elsewhere for years now that's why
marjorie
speaking of tucker carlson
we've talked before about projection
when they talk a lot about something the
left is doing or should do
really we should be asking ourselves
aren't they the ones that are doing it
and tucker carlson is now calling for
democrats to de-escalate their rhetoric
because it might actually lead to you
know anything from real-world violence
to extremism uh tucker that's what
you're actually doing and in fact when
tucker's rants appear verbatim in the
buffalo shooter's manifesto
you know that he's desperate to push
attention anywhere else that he can it's
projection or the pot calling the kettle
black or you know what whatever analogy
or metaphor you want to use take a
listen to this from last night
because rhetoric has its own internal
logic right experience you can talk
yourself into things we've all done that
democrats are doing it right now
and what they're talking themselves into
right now is quote something worse it's
scary uh-oh it is time to pull back
it is time to de-escalate
otherwise this is going to get really
ugly really soon well it did get really
ugly really soon a guy just went to
buffalo
to search for black people to shoot
because he believed in the great
replacement or white replacement theory
which tucker and other of his right-wing
media cohorts have propped up he's
talking about the wrong people you know
it's a it's it's it's almost like he's
saying
these satanic pro-pedophile democrats
who are desperate to forcibly inject you
with a vaccine that's killing hundreds
of people
those people need to tone it down
because the rhetoric is getting
dangerous no the the rhetoric is coming
from their side and
one of the most notable
uh kind of narcissistic
traits
is these extreme double standards that
include projection
and accusing others of that which they
are actually guilty of doing it's one of
the many tactics that's often used by
narcissists and abusers and manipulators
and on and on and on their rhetoric
already incited an insurrectious riot on
january 6 2021
they talk about dangerous illegals
against whom we need to be protected
blah blah blah when undocumented and
documented immigrants commit crime at a
lower rate than americans the constant
gun rhetoric we might need second
amendment solutions we might need to be
ready to take up arms against whoever
talk of civil war which we will talk
about a little bit later and the belief
that they harbor that increasingly
violence is acceptable in order to
achieve political results it's coming
from their side save the occasional you
know eco-terrorist or whatever it's
almost all coming from their side we'll
have these clips on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show we're continuing our
conversations with a number of different
candidates running in these 2022 midterm
elections and today i'm going to be
speaking with bobby pyton bobby is a
republican running for election to the
united states senate to represent
illinois and bobby's worked as a
portfolio manager he's on the republican
primary ballot in illinois
on june 28th the winner of that primary
will face incumbent democratic senator
tammy duckworth in november uh bobby
great to have you on i appreciate it
thank you so much for having me you know
these conversations as many in my
audience always tell me can be so
illuminating because i as someone of the
left want to hear
the ideas of people that are republicans
and that are on the right and sometimes
the ideas make some sense and sometimes
they don't and we talk about it and we
we sort of figure it out and talk
through things so just to start i've
been doing this almost like as a just
gut check to to start figuring out where
people are so forgive me if the answer
to this question is easy
who's the current president of the
united states
who's the current president well
i guess um i guess it's a it's a funny
it's a funny question is it really yeah
i do think it we live in a very
interesting time
where
um
we have there's forces beyond our
visibility
that uh like supernatural supernatural
not supernatural oh there's there's
there's a group of extremely uh well
wealthy beyond wealthy like su uber
wealthy individuals not just in the
united states but globally okay that
call the shots on both parties not just
one party okay and and so it's it's
almost as though there's a bunch of
horse trading taking place behind the
scenes
and so you know from that perspective i
do believe the will of the american
people um was ignored
in 2020
and uh the person that's in there is is
the person that these globalists
put in and and that's that's that's in
and i you know what i would tell you is
i have overwhelming proof i'll i'll
actually be releasing uh proof from ill
about illinois tomorrow
general flynn will be in town i have a
fundraiser for my campaign anne
vandersteel doug billings jovan pulitzer
liz harris from arizona edward solomon
who's done work mathematical work on
proving
that our elections
across the aisle folks the uniparty is
very real and frankly it's undermining
you and me okay but so bobby that's
that's a lot so let's take it piece by
piece sure who are the rich globalists
you that you're talking about
well there's
there's a there's a there's a there's a
corporate
class okay uh a global corporate class
that exists that uh
considers themselves to have more rights
than any individuals within any nation
state who are they
ceos of major global corporations but
can you name some specific people so
like for example um
you know uh think of blackrock
uh blackrock controls nine trillion
dollars of assets through their their uh
their structure uh he's he's been in
control for over 30 years okay um who
else won uh bill gates is one who
parlayed his fortune in microsoft into
um other areas okay um you know so you
can you can argue that elon musk is one
who's who's kind of like leaning from
left back to right you know possibly
right for the first time in his life
okay that's another one um you know
michael eisner of disney used to be one
before he retired uh then there's always
this legacy wealth that we all know
exists
like the rockefellers um you know the
duponts
for example the dupont family backed the
individual running for u.s senate in
pennsylvania there's like 4 000 duponts
okay you know and and so it's it's a
it's it's not it's not like one boogie
man this i got it it's a bunch of people
okay and so
um do you trust the results from
pennsylvania from earlier this week
where this right-wing guy uh who
believes the election was stolen in 2020
doug mastriano he won on tuesday do you
trust those results or do you question
them
i think that um
that the results
are are
are um what's the word i would use is uh
they're they're probably manufactured to
some degree yes so i think it's it's
across party lines so doug didn't really
win
well first of all here's my question is
if if we were playing a board game you
and i and two other people
and um
and you know somehow we knew that there
was some some some stuff flawed with the
way the game was set up okay and we were
playing and you know one of us ended up
winning right but we knew that it was
flawed massively would it really feel
like a win
okay but i'm asking a different question
and i love this because we're really
getting down to brass tacks here in in
20 in the november 2020 election joe
biden was awarded the state of
pennsylvania do you believe joe biden
won in 2020 in pennsylvania absolutely
not okay and i have and let me explain
how but i'll let you explain it but i
want to just make sure we go
sequentially
two days ago doug mastriano won in
pennsylvania's gubernatorial primary do
you believe he actually won
i think that i i don't i have not looked
at the data to make that assessment oh
so i looked at the data uh with regards
to 2020 i actually broke out all 67
counties of the state of pennsylvania
and i showed
how they had destroyed entire last names
of voters from both republican and the
democratic side
to create the outcome that they wanted
mathematically
and it showed up in the voter
registration files in the final result
they literally destroyed 695 000
individuals
names
that didn't vote the way their algorithm
wanted and it's a brilliant way to hide
their crime why didn't a single court
accept this well first of all a couple
things number one
uh that that information was provided to
the georgia state senate okay wait hold
on you're talking about pennsylvania but
now you're talking about georgia because
i i released those results i testified
before the georgia state senate with the
pennsylvania results because those votes
were shifted to georgia
they shifted votes from pennsylvania to
georgia like a stock portfolio algorithm
and who did it people in pennsylvania
are people in georgia
somebody whoever has the power to
control the the voter registration files
and the voting system of those two
states didn't what person would have
control over both systems in two
different states i think that there's
multiple
entities that probably have that the the
means to do that like let's just say the
dnc and the rnc
maybe they did it together for all i
know the dnc and the rnc
took control of the pennsylvania and
georgia systems to shift votes from one
to the other but biden won both so what
was the point in shifting them
because because once again i think they
do some horse trading behind the scenes
both parties okay and they and they
collude to create the outcome that they
agree upon okay based on these mega
donors all right so to go back to the
question who's currently the president
do you have an answer you can give
i think that um
i think that right now in in the
international arena okay of the world
uh president biden is recognized as the
president of the united states do you
believe that someone else like maybe
trump is actually the president
i have no information to make that kind
of judgment or assessment okay you know
so no i'm not living in a delusional
world
you know where somebody is thinking you
know there's some kind of like
uh secret shadow presidency or something
like no no no no i don't i don't believe
in any of that oh but i do agree with
what elon musk said uh which he he said
whoever controls biden's teleprompter is
really running this country okay
with that statement there are so many
fascinating things in a q a you did with
a paper not long ago let me actually
mention exactly what paper it is um it
was uh
it was a local newspaper shaw local um
the shaw local news network you did a q
a it's fascinating before we get on to
the substance bobby
in looking at your answers you do
something that trump does which is you
randomly capitalize words in the middle
of sentences that aren't proper nouns so
like in your answers you randomly
capitalize the word farming and the word
chemicals and i could give you a dozen
other examples can you help me
understand what's with the random
capitalization yeah my wife uh my wife
it's a big pet peeve of hers so i'm it's
a wonderful question and sometimes
and it's very hard because when you
write something um you you don't always
necessarily have people key in on
certain words so i do know that it's not
grammatically correct to capitalize i've
had this discussion with my wife plenty
of times
and i i say i capitalize it because i
want to catch people's attention instead
of italicizing the word or bolding it i
do something that causes them to pause
and so i hope it was effective with you
you know she thinks it's ineffective to
communicate this way i agree with your
wife i agree with your wife it made no
it was such a distraction because i was
like does bobby
think these are proper nouns or what's
going on
okay so it's a personality quirk
you know to your point
my wife has brought it up others have
brought it up maybe i maybe it's time
for me to stop doing that something to
think about okay good so now let me ask
you another question
in this same q a with the new local
newspaper
when you were asked about january 6th
um one of the things you said is you
really want antifa and black lives
matter investigated for what happened on
january 6th do you have any evidence
that antifa and black lives matter are
the ones that committed crimes at the
capitol on that day
well first of all um
i'm not sure if i linked it right with
that question i might have mentioned it
in the same question but i'd have to
double check i don't have those notes in
front of me okay but in terms of those
two groups anti-first amendment which is
ant antifa right it's a play on words
it's pretty brilliant uh no it actually
means it means anti-fascist well it
means anti-first amendment well no you'd
have to the people the people who
it's sort of like if you told me my name
means something different like if i'm
coming up with the name i'm coming up
with it because i know what it means to
me right antifa says it's anti-fascist
we have to go by what they are meaning
with it don't we
well i mean that's it
you know it's kind of funny for you to
say that because on the left right now
there's people that identify as being a
woman that are biologically a male and
you know and and they could they could
tell you that they have to have a
certain pronoun
so i understand we're going to agree to
disagree on what it means well right
let's see the focus is so you were asked
about the riots and what you said about
that was that it was a peaceful
gathering manipulated by the political
establishment and you want antifa and
blm investigated for it yes i do think i
do not have evidence yeah those two were
involved i i you know but i think that i
do believe that people from both sides
of the aisle the uni party
corrupt democrats corrupt republicans
were both involved in staging this
incident
um in in in a way that
if you notice what happened after that
event yeah we never did get to see
any disputes with you know like the you
know the the floor of congress to debate
the merits of issues that arose in
uh the ballots properly in all these
different states they they kind of brush
through that much faster as a result of
that event well yes because they
realized that it was going to serve no
productive purpose that at the end of
the day there wasn't really any
substantive evidence or fraud nor a
legal mechanism to deny joe biden the
presidency and they said it's the middle
of the night we all want to go home
let's do what is obviously going to be
the correct thing to do you know what
i'd love to do david yeah i'm going to
if you don't mind yeah make sure you
send me your email address please
tomorrow you'll send me the evidence
okay i will send you a deck yeah with
regards to my presentation find some of
the slides from tomorrow fine and i'll
se and i'm more than happy if you have a
dropbox okay i'm glad to send you uh
some data for you to review from the
voter registration files of the five
battleground states the work that i did
as well as my write-ups and i'll gladly
let you read it debate it it's all i'm
glad to do it i'm glad to do it but
bobby in terms of my question on antifa
and blm
you believe people from both sides were
involved but i believe that before you
you said that you said you have no
evidence antifa or blm were involved
that's what you said right i do not have
evidence that they were involved i do
think that they are based on other
things that i've seen but i don't have
the smoking gun so to speak i'm not an
investigator i'm asking that there there
is an investigation held and there have
been so many which have found either
that joe biden won by even more or like
it doesn't sound like you're necessarily
satisfied with investigations when they
don't go your way what type of
investigation would you accept
well well a couple things yeah okay so
um
number one
when you when you look at um
um
let's you let's talk about the state of
arizona okay okay so arizona
there's maricopa was where the audit
took place right everybody knows that
and you were involved with the cyber
ninja stuff right i was involved with no
no i was not employed during that audit
okay work on the on the on the voter
registration files okay and proved out
that there was a set of voters inserted
into the voter registration files that
can be called upon when needed
to sway the um the results in any
particular precinct and they had they
all were registered to the same address
is that correct no no they weren't
that's not that's not the case that they
were all registered to the same address
oh what what happens
is
in in the case so let's let's talk about
why you need very little to to rig an
election especially when you look at the
results okay if if there was there's an
average of about 1 000 people per
precinct in this country so if the vote
came out to be
501 to 499
you're talking about what you're talking
about a two vote differential right 501
minus 499 yes so now if you wanted to
uh sway that result the other way from
501 to 409 you only need three votes
okay you need to go from 501 to 502. so
three divided by
a thousand is 30 basis points it's three
tenths of one percent so
a thousand goes into one million
a thousand times
so per million people that voted three
times a thousand is three thousand votes
so in the case of arizona
3.6 million approximately people voted
so three times 3.6 is 10.8 000. you only
need to steal 10
800 votes to affect the election if it
was 501 to 499 and you put it to 502 501
502. but this is an imaginary scenario
where you're saying
every precinct okay all right go ahead
no but here here's what i would say the
data
is when when you mapped out the data
across the 700 i think it was 742
precincts
within maricopa i think i believe there
are 742 precincts and you calculated
what was the number that would be needed
in advance
to to rig the election
and you could generate it before a
single ballot was cast and the numbers
came out
the way they came out
on election day you would call in the
question mathematically how can somebody
come up with
the algorithm for how to do this before
a single ballot was cast what evidence
do you have that said anybody did that
though you're just looking at the
numbers
i'm more than happy to send it to you
okay i'll send you edward solomon's it's
coming out tomorrow right well
well i was explaining arizona tomorrow
i'm going to explain illinois oh in
illinois
i've never
exposed illinois but i'm going to expose
the senate race
for durbin that took place in 2000 and
the senate race the u.s senate race for
duckworth my opponent if i make it
through the primary right in 2016. and i
will show you the data i will do a video
actually i i'm not sure if we're going
to live stream it but i will gladly send
you my supporting documentaries
my video and and i will and i'll explain
um how they're modifying the voter
registration files
and using optimizers as well as random
functions that exist in microsoft excel
to do this anybody will be able to
replicate what i'm talking about if they
have microsoft excel okay
bobby i've got to ask you because we are
out of time what would what evidence if
it could be presented would convince you
that joe biden just won in 2020.
is there such evidence if anybody could
show it to you that would make you say
you know what biden won
i think the evidence that would convince
me
that
that biden won
is is if you said bobby in your state of
illinois yeah there's 8.9 million people
registered to vote okay and um of those
8.9 million people
um this is how many that you know we're
between you know the legal age to vote
you know 18 plus
and um um they they they exist in our
society in the form of
um you know there was six million tax
returns filed or there was a 150 you
know like 500 000 social security checks
paid into the state or you know 200 000
uh you know covet checks that were
cashed and and if if i can see the the
receipts of the economic activity of the
of the state of who's doing these votes
and it ties out to our federal
tax receipts or our federal spend
you know because i'm not saying you know
i don't if somebody's retired and they
don't have a a tax return and they still
get government money they still have a
right to vote so i'm all for like oh
this is how many receive the check that
voted this is how many paid taxes that
voted and then if if all of a sudden
there's no record that they exist
economically speaking you know um you
know like that would that would put this
to rest for me real quick i'd be like
okay it seems we have all of that that's
strange listen
we don't have it uh we don't have a
cross-reference with the actual votes
that take place in our system at the
current time is your assertion that joe
biden didn't even really win illinois is
that what you're claiming
i don't know if he won illinois
you don't know i i i know that he went
he i could tell you right now that in
illinois based on my my research
there's well over 1.6 million fraudulent
registrations in the state of illinois
at the present time
okay but so you're you're saying that
even illinois which was won
by democrats in 2016
2012 2008 2004
2000 etc uh 1996. i mean you're you're
saying that
those were all fraudulent or just in
2020 the democratic i think that we need
to look at all the elections going back
at least 20 years since the machines
entered the scene oh boy so so you think
maybe even like bill clinton's win in
illinois in 92 was fraudulent
i didn't say that we didn't have
machines back then oh okay 96 1996 the
machines came in after this criminal by
the name of george bush
uh i believe he stole the election from
al gore uh in florida with the hanging
chad and
uh incident but in 2000 and 2004 where
the dem where al gore and kerry won
illinois even though bush had the
machines you think those might have been
probably the machines came in after the
2000 election okay so 2004. yeah so i'm
saying is what i'm saying is that that
that event
where george bush
stole the election with the hanging chad
incident with his brother who was the
governor at the time yeah jeb bush
um that ushered in these machines and i
think ever since these machines have
come online i think it makes it easy to
possibly manipulate and steal elections
across the whole the whole ticket and
look the math will show it i i'm gonna
i'm very happy i i will send you
all of my stuff
and uh and i it's all gonna be presented
tomorrow i have over i think about 300
plus people coming tomorrow i invited
the press to be there good i and uh and
uh i will i will open it up for peer
review and people that love math and
statistics they can look at it
themselves and see what i'm talking
about and love it if you wanted to talk
about it after you go through it and
pick it apart allow me to do yeah i will
take a look at it and then we will go
from there and you know bobby i have a
feeling you're going to take these
beliefs to your grave i don't think
you'll ever be disabused of any of these
thoughts i don't i don't think the
evidence really matters
i think i think that um
you know i think i think that what will
play out will play out but this is what
i do can i just say this yeah
when this plays out the way it's gonna
be meant to play out yep
my biggest hope about this whole thing
yes is that when you have a difference
or i have a difference and who we back
that goes in you know to to run for
office
that your vote is not diluted one iota
and my vote is not deluded and right now
i don't think either one of us i do not
have any confidence that my vote is not
being undermined in some way or your
vote might not be undermined in some way
and so i will continue to work to get
that solved because at the end of the
day we're all americans first we are
yeah
look my my the godfather of my son
is is a huge democrat he um i think he
actually you know he calls pelosi his
girl when he was living out there he's
an airline pilot and he's the godfather
and you know last year i love the guy
i've known him over 20 years we disagree
but we both want it to be fair you know
and i think i think at first he was
skeptical
i've sent him information over the past
year he sees it he's more open-minded to
seeing if it truly is taking place but
the reality is is in my state of
illinois they're both in on it folks
both the republicans and the democrats
are doing this to us and i don't think
it was just in 2020 i think it goes back
at least two decades all right well
we're gonna look at all of it we've been
speaking with bobby pyton who is running
for u.s senate in illinois he is in a
primary which is at the end of june if
he wins he will face incumbent
democratic senator tammy duckworth
bobby illuminating i can't that quite
literally you're lit up your face is
completely lit up
what's going on
i don't know but it's been it's been an
illuminating conversation metaphorically
and literally hey can i can i mention to
your viewers to check me out at
bobbypiton.com or on telegram yes and
and please get us the data on illinois
and we will look at it very strongly
awesome i really appreciate it thank you
so much david thank you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so we're right in the middle of a really
interesting confrontation within the
republican party this isn't normal this
isn't typical former president donald
trump has endorsed david perdue
in the republican georgia gubernatorial
primary on the other hand trump's own
vice president mike pence has endorsed
purdue's opponent brian kemp the
incumbent in that very same georgia
gubernatorial republican primary today
tonight
we will hopefully know the results of
that election it's not looking good for
david perdue meaning it's not looking
good for donald trump's endorsement but
the part i want to focus on today
because we'll have those results
tomorrow is the increased escalation and
tension and attacks between donald trump
and mike pence most of it by the way
coming from trump in the direction of
pence yesterday donald trump appeared on
the real america's voice show outside
the beltway it's a completely unhinged
delusional show but a very manic
sounding trump flipped out on mike pence
in this hysterical interview let's take
a look at this and remember this is not
normal and trump's seemingly turning on
almost everyone common a move of
narcissists
as soon as people are no longer useful
to you or loyal to you or willing to do
whatever you tell them to do you turn on
them take a look
well i'm very disappointed in mike as a
lot of people are and uh he is uh he
just greatly disappointed me he had a
great opportunity and all he had to do
is send it back to the legislatures now
remember
trump continues to insist that mike
pence should have and could have
uh rejected the electoral results on
january 6 2021
and say states each of you decide each
of you decide who actually won in your
state now unfortunately for trump pence
couldn't do that there's actually no
real mechanism the states had already
said here are our votes it's delusional
but trump continues to attack pence for
it
because when you had all of that
ammunition when you had all of those
things being said about the election and
you had all of the proof that peter
navarro and others many others were
talking about it would have been very
easy to send it back and have them come
back so i'm
very disappointed at what uh
at the stance he took
but that's his uh you know where we're a
country it was very interesting they
said he had no choice but in the
meantime they go and try and change the
law so he can't do it so that means he
did have a choice so we'll have to see
we'll have to see when it all happens uh
but all i know is this our country has
probably never been worse than it is
right now i think we're in the greatest
danger ever of a nuclear war i would
have never thought that would have
happened we're in the greatest danger of
a nuclear war where
so as you can see the the question was
about the possibility that mike pence
will run against trump
and trump's he he just can't stay
focused on one thing he's talking about
nuclear war he's talking about the
impossibility of what he wanted mike
pence to do but the important thing is
he essentially at this point has
completely turned on his own former vice
president that's not normal great danger
we're not a respected country anymore so
get out there so important this is a
very very
big election that's coming up and by the
way on respected country
this is not a matter of of my opinion
it's a matter of global opinion but it's
not a matter of my opinion
every
serious global study of america's
reputation around the world shows that
since trump left and biden came in
respect for the united states has
increased in just about every country
not every country i think russia did
prefer trump uh but just about every
country trump's just wrong
this is going to be big stuff so david
perdue
just work hard david work hard we're
going to have a big day tomorrow john
gordon also jody heist patrick witt and
you know what you have to get out there
and just vote for every single one
including jake evans because jake evans
is going to do a perfect job so good
luck everybody
yeah mr president just one last thing i
i just want everybody to know i never
said this to you publicly
but that the worst thing mike pence did
you on january 6
is not share
that fake legal opinion he had with
either you or pat sip along the white
house legal counsel he had it this is
peter navarro by the way trump's former
economic adviser a a lunatic in his own
right duty to you sir as
commander-in-chief he had a duty to this
country he had to do the people of
america to show that flawed legal
opinion he did not do that instead he
stuck the knife not your back but in
your chest and for that nobody in this
country should consider mike pence to be
anything other than
but retired
all right
wow
uh did guys this this is outrageous this
is this is bizarre we you you don't see
stuff like this and the real question
and my hope is that the answer is yes
is will this rift ultimately work to
[Music]
hurt
the republican voters in the sense of
will they stay home will they say well i
don't know i mean
pence is endorsing this person but pence
is bad according to trump but trump is
good according
maybe i'll just stay home i don't know
that's that's my interest in this is in
it being bad for republicans we got one
new poll about 2022 yesterday that
doesn't look good for republicans let's
see if it continues and ultimately we
will know what happens in november we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 davidp
here's a caller who wants to know
are democrats abandoning the democratic
party
because of woke
listen to this
hey david parkman or park men uh first
time uh
caller uh wanting to uh ask you about
uh the left and uh wanted you to
speak on people kind of leaving the left
and turning away from the party because
it's becoming
a little bit too you know woke
um an example of maybe what bill maher
was saying where
you know
most
democrats classic democrats are staying
as the party is moving along um
appreciate it uh big fan thanks uh david
pass or pachmann or passman
thanks
yeah very very much struggling with my
name so listen this is just a question
of party registration
if we look at the party registration
trend going back to 2004 which is 18
years
you see a similar percentage of the
country registered as democrats it
really hasn't moved very much right
after barack obama won in 2008 you saw a
little bit of a spike in the number of
americans who were registered as
democrats and then you saw it settle
back down again but it's basically been
extraordinarily stable for at least 18
years so
when all you know there's all these
movements that claim all of these people
are abandoning the democratic party
there was the so-called blexit movement
black exit of black people leaving the
democratic party it's not actually shown
in the data the democratic party
registration is very stable
uh black folks still overwhelmingly
voting for democrats um the claim that
the democratic party is being abandoned
because of supposed wokism
it's not showing up in any data and so
that's what i go by my opinion or
whether i personally know someone that
has left or joined the democratic party
it doesn't really matter what matters is
what is the data show the data doesn't
show that people are abandoning the
democratic party we have a great bonus
show for you today an appeals court
finds florida's new social media law
unconstitutional the supreme court makes
it tougher for inmates to win release
from prison because of bad lawyering
they say they've received and lastly
starbucks is completely exiting russia
joining mcdonald's some mcdonald's and a
bunch of other brands all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access